the guy we used to use to warm up our
crowds way back in the early 90s we
found out visiting Los Angeles today and
he asked if he could come out and just
for old times sake
pump up the crowd again you meet Stanley
Stanley in the old days clearly from the
old days
yeah amazing Stanley I haven't seen him
have you seen him I haven't seen 20
years I thought it might be fun to bring
him out and he used to do a great job
with our crowd I thought you guys might
enjoy
[Applause]
good morning make some noise Thank You
Akane
[Applause]
he's doing Conan we going are you doing
there Stanley make some noise okay
if you going all right hot crowd Stanley
if you don't mind me asking why are you
in a scooter I'm not gonna lie to you
Conan after the divorce I kind of I kind
of turned to cake and I kind of gave up
make some noise make some noise I'm
sorry to hear that but Stephanie why
don't you just go ahead and kind of warm
up the crowd like he used to all right
let's see what Stanley and I Kohner that
would be incredible you make some noise
make some noise
how's everyone doing
you guys having a good time you guys
have any good make some noise
Conan I got him jazzed up okay that's
great you really got him going jazz yeah
the word okay once you just once you
step back stage but Thank You Stanley
no no no no I got to do crowd work watch
this I'm gonna do crowd way okay Joe
maybe you know you don't okey and I have
never been there because traveling is
very difficult for me make some noise
make some more no Stanley para Dan Lee
that was some quick you had there I
think we've warned him it up enough
thank you no no no no I got a big closer
watch my clothes you want to see my
closer hey who likes t-shirts
Oh God now
I got a t-shirt cannon I got a keeper
where's my t-shirt cannon where's my
t-shirt cannon where is it you can get
that right why are you sitting there
like an idiot get up just give me my
t-shirt cannon play all right watch this
oh good more these heavier than I
thought they were I just got a [ __ ]
make some noise make weight back down
that's not good I didn't need a whole
new gun
no no one even got it to be fun I mean I
no one got a t-shirt sitting there it's
not work and make some noise all right
[Applause]
they do have a great show tonight from
the new movie hell or high water Academy
we're burning actor Jeff Bridges is on
both bridges
oh no not Beau Bridges Jeff Bridges from
from Animal Planet no we also have
Comedy Central's roastmaster general
Jeff Ross these that guy is great on the
Food Network he's not on the Food
Network comedian Brent Sullivan is we've
got a lot more show coming up we'll take
a break we'll be right back
you